[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui m'a poussé à venir ici c'est pas
mal de choses déjà je suis de la région
plus ou moins même si je suis pas
purement de songo je viens d'un petit
village qui était nominé d'ici il ya
tellement besoin dans le secteur que si
on a un qui a envie de venir s'installer
et d'ouvrir une clinique pour faire je
sais pas moi par exemple un lien entre
la médecine de ville et les urgences ou
simplement de se poser pour créer son
cabinet même c'est quasiment une
certitude que d'avoir non seulement du
boulot un boulot super riches et
intéressants
et puis une petite girafe mais sinon pas
d'inflexion où je les marchés en
montagne je vais faire du twr lg les
mouches qui sont à un quart d'heure
d'ici
si vous avez envie de voir des lacs il
n'y a pas de souci comme dit si vous
avez envie de vous balayant celui-ci de
quoi faire et puis bon sortir ma moto
aller faire un tour sous le soleil ou
d'autres d'autres guides ce type là
j'avais envie 2011 qui part très très
loin aussi avec plein de petits trésors
des fois ça va le chercher mais y'a des
trucs super intéressant vous avez une
route qui mène directement sur colmar
vous pouvez des ceintures belfort pour
tout ce qui est côté français et si vous
êtes un petit peu curieux et
berbérophones
on peut basculer du côté de balle du
côté de l'allemagne en beaucoup beaucoup
de choses sur les territoires
limitrophes surtout sur cette question
des trois frontières on est vraiment au
coeur d'un territoire qui permet d'être
très ouverts en fait
j'exerce ici à l'offre le métier de
masseur kinésithérapeute au sein de la
structure sise à qu'on a créé il ya deux
ans qui regroupe vraiment plu à
professionnels de santé et travail à
plusieurs c'est quand même plus sympa
on peut faire carrière carrément dans la
région de l'offre ça fait deux enfants
d'installer et on va s'agrandir
prochainement
[Musique]
il ya 20 minutes des muses on a vingt
minutes de belfort on est à 10 minutes
de cernay burnotte où tout chez nous bon
accueil
[Musique]
on y va la nature et on profite tout ce
qui est sport de nature
donc ça pied trail les sports d'hiver
[Musique]
on a été deux à reprendre le cabinet
avant de reprendre on a eu ce projet de
maison de santé
on a voulu monter quelque chose dont on
puisse avoir à la fois des échanges
entre médecins mais également des
échanges entre différentes professions
médicales ou paramédicales là les
décisions vont se prendre à plusieurs
parce que chacun aura en fait les
expertises de sa profession dès le
départ on avait cette envie de faire de
la médecine générale mais peut-être
d'une manière un peu différente qui nous
permettrait aussi de concilier la vie de
famille
lavigne extra médicale et puis après il
ya la qualité de vie moi je retrouve ici
en tout cas pas ce qu'on peut faire du
sport parce que
parce que justement on n'a pas toutes
les nuisances qu'ils sont liés à la
ville on n'a jamais de bouchons il ya
beaucoup de services qui sont proposés
sur canal
et donc ça toute la vallée en
bénéficient
[Musique]
le centre hospitalier de guebwiller
c'est un établissement je dirais à
taille humaine qui est ancré dans la
ville les petits mais comprend quand
même de la médecine de la chirurgie en
programmer des urgences un centre
périnatal de proximité car up date et la
maternité des soins de suite et
rééducation et une maison de retraite
[Musique]
alors pour une ville de guebwiller qui
comprend je crois dans les onze mille
habitants c'est un vrai plus parce que
on a des manques de médecins
généralistes et spécialistes
et en fait guebwiller est liée aux
hôpitaux civils de colmar on est en
direction commune euros logis la dermato
aujourd'hui on a vraiment beaucoup de
choses et y compris de la chirurgie en
programmée avec les spécialistes qui se
déplace aussi
[Musique]
on est dans une vallée qui est très
jolie feinte faut dire ce qui est on est
dans une ville à taille humaine avec ses
petits commerces donc c'est toujours
intéressant si jamais on veut aller à
colmar ou à mulhouse voilà ça à 20 30
minutes
donc en termes de cadre de vie si on
aime les randonnées les vignes et le
vent fait c'est une bonne manière de
venir ici
[Musique]